do you compare yourself to other people
do you think things to yourself like
i'm not as good as that guy in sport i'm
not as smart as well built fast
energetic social attractive rich stylish
and a list just goes on if this is you
then always remember this you should
never compare yourself to other people
your confidence in who you are does not
come from other people because you were
never created to be like them i heard
this quote somewhere
when you stop comparing yourself with
others you begin respecting your own
uniqueness
every one of us we are all unique
different so never wish that you were
someone else because every second you do
it is a second you waste your own life
now if you compare yourself to others
and you think more in the opposite
direction of i am better than that guy
i'm better smarter faster bigger cooler
look at me i'm more attractive if you do
that all the time ask yourself and be
honest why do you do it
do you try to build your own self-esteem
that way does it make you feel important
better about yourself it is sad if that
is what makes you feel better about
yourself the need to walk on other
people to try and elevate yourself
and that is not the way that you build
self-confidence it is actually the
opposite
listen carefully confidence isn't
walking into a house or room thinking
you're better than everyone there
it is going in knowing that you don't
have to compare yourself to anyone at
all if you feel that need to be better
than other people just to feel good
about yourself then that's sad and what
it actually shows is
insecurity and here is the biggest
problem
if you compare yourself to other people
no matter the reason why you do it
here's the biggest problem the problem
is that the grass on the other side
always looks greener
but it isn't
when you watch other people on social
media you just see their highlights you
don't see what's going on behind the
scenes
their real lives so what you're actually
doing is you're comparing
yourself your behind the scenes to other
people's highlights and if you live this
way
you will never be content with your own
life because if you always compare
yourself to other people
it steals your joy your uniqueness and
it steals listen carefully your own
real identity if there's one thing you
need to learn in this life
and even if you have to force yourself
to do it
it is to respect your own identity
respect yourself
respect your own uniqueness does it not
feel great to know that there has never
been someone exactly like you in this
world and there never will be now most
of you here on the channel know that i
believe in god
and i know that you are not here just by
random chance for no reason at all you
are created with a purpose and god
created you for a reason
and your job is to find out why what is
that reason what is your purpose in this
life
let me share a bible verse with you the
psalm 139 13
for you formed my inward parts
you knitted me together in my mother's
womb i praise you for i am fearfully and
wonderfully made
wonderful are your works my soul knows
it very well
my frame was not hidden from you when it
was being made in secret intricately
woven in the depths of the earth
your eyes saw my unformed substance and
your book were written every one of them
the days that were formed for me when as
yet there was none of them
god knows you better than you even know
yourself
because thousands of years before you
were even born he saw you he saw your
whole life
and so you got to stop comparing
yourself to other people you got to run
your own race
because everyone me you we all have our
own journey in this short temporary
world and that is why you can't compare
your own journey to someone else now
remember
life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys